The SCP Foundation has a reputation for cold,
inhumane conditions, but being contained as
an anomalous human doesn’t mean your stay
inside a secure facility has to be as bad
as it might seem at first.
Of course, more dangerous anomalous entities,
such as SCP-076, codenamed Able, are locked
away in a containment chamber outfitted with
maximum security precautions and guarded by
the Foundation’s most well-trained and heavily
armed personnel, but not every anomaly poses
a danger, and the Foundation realizes that.
Sure, the monsters like SCP-106 or SCP-096,
who need no introduction, aren’t exactly
treated to a bed and breakfast every morning,
but those lower on the danger scale can get
pretty comfortable inside their new home,
depending on how well they’ve behaved and
how little of a threat they pose, of course.
Take for instance SCP-076’s less violent
brother, SCP-073, also known as Cain.
SCP-073 is peaceful, a complete contrast to
SCP-076’s destructive fits of violence and
rage, and as a result, he’s treated like
nearly any other low-threat anomalous humanoid.
Amenities, clothes, maybe even some time in
the Foundation’s recreational spaces if
they’re extra well-behaved, it’s true
that the Foundation has been doing a lot for
the anomalies it contains, especially in recent
years.
After all, anomalies contained by the Foundation
are, containment breaches aside, supposed
to be contained for life.
The least the Foundation can do with all of
their seemingly infinite money and funding
is show them an easier time while they’re
there.
Sometimes, anomalous humanoids are integrated
into the Foundation’s command structure.
Such is the case with the mysterious Dr. Clef,
a former Global Occult Coalition agent turned
Foundation operative with reality bending
powers and a penchant for neutralizing dangerous
anomalies.
Or Dr. Jack Bright, who continued to work
as a Foundation researcher following an accident
with SCP-963, an amulet that made his consciousness
immortal.
Or Kain Pathos Crow, once an ordinary Foundation
scientist, now a golden retriever blessed
with super-intelligence thanks to an experiment
gone wrong, or right, depending on who you
ask.
It’s true, the Foundation is definitely
more accepting of the anomalous than it may
initially seem.
Let’s take a look at a particularly notable
anomaly contained by the Foundation, SCP-166.
SCP-166 can be seen as a baseline example
of how the Foundation treats the average humanoid
anomaly that doesn’t pose a significant
threat to the organization or society at large.
SCP-166 is contained at the famous Site-19
inside a hermetically sealed antechamber outfitted
with an industrial air purifier.
Personnel assigned to SCP-166’s containment
chamber must wear specially designated biohazard
suits before entering, and keep them on at
all times, lest they succumb to SCP-166’s
anomalous effects.
SCP-166 is a teenage girl of european descent,
possessing certain bodily features found on
a reindeer.
She has antlers, hooved feet, and a short
tail.
All that’s missing is a red nose, right?
But despite looking like one of Santa’s
most trusted four-legged helpers, SCP-166
has little to do with the animal.
In fact, scans of her DNA reveal no irregular
genetic traits.
To the instruments used to record such things,
she's a completely ordinary human.
Her reindeer features are, according to some
Foundation theorists, a reflection of her
connection with nature, and a remnant of her
past.
But we’ll get to that.
Aside from her fluffy parts, what makes SCP-166
so anomalous?
As it turns out, SCP-166 possesses an incredibly
strong anomalous ability.
Any artificial objects, meaning those that
are man-made, within a 15 meter radius of
SCP-166 will return to an unworked state.
For example, a car placed within SCP-166’s
range will return to a composite of paint,
metals, leather, and plastics over time.
These higher complexity objects, such as vehicles
or electronics, are affected more quickly
by SCP-166, with degradation of their metallic
components giving out and causing massive
structural failure, resulting in an unusable
object.
More natural objects made of rudimentary materials,
such as stone buildings and products made
of organic materials will decay at a much
slower, nearly imperceptible rate.
So SCP-166’s containment chamber and containment
situation is more than safe, though it might
need to be repaired and touched up over the
years.
SCP-166 is very in touch with nature, as her
appearance would suggest.
In fact, in areas where objects degraded as
a result of her influence, flowers and plant
growth will begin to appear.
Sometimes this foliage will grow in places
that should otherwise be impossible for it
to, such as ID scanners or security cameras.
You could imagine that the inside of the chamber
is practically a botanical garden.
Still, the Foundation has to be careful with
how SCP-166’s containment chamber is constructed,
and who enters it, as the degrading deer-girl
harbors a particular sensitivity to artificial
materials and pollutants, such as smoke or
pesticides.
Inhalation of, or contact with one of these
airy substances causes SCP-166 to grow ulcers,
and suffer symptoms of asthma attacks.
Even being in close proximity with a smoker
can cause SCP-166 pain, with one instance
prompting a severe asthma attack despite the
Foundation doctor in question having not smoked
a cigarette in over three weeks.
If you need another reason to stay away from
smoking, do it for SCP-166.
Isn’t she adorable?
You wouldn’t want to give her a panic attack,
would you?
Not only are SCP-166’s visitors limited
and screened beforehand, but her clothing
consists of organic cloth, so as not to trigger
a degradation effect.
All of her meals must be prepared by a trained
Foundation chef and followed according to
a specific set of guidelines, with as little
inorganic additives as possible.
The Foundation has to be a little bit more
careful than usual with the items requested
by SCP-166, not only due to her anomalous
ability to degrade objects, but due to her
mysterious past and connection with a small
convent of nuns in Ireland.
We’ll explain.
You see, like most humanoid anomalies, the
Foundation has allowed SCP-166 to put in requests
for personal items she might find missing
from her containment.
Now, the Foundation may deny these items,
for a variety of reasons, but there’s also
a chance they won’t.
To date, SCP-166 has requested a copy of the
Holy Bible, a Catholic rosary, and various
books and magazines involving religious content,
all of which were approved by Site-19’s
director Sophia Light.
SCP-166 also requested access to a Catholic
priest for confession, mass, and other sacraments.
This request was initially denied, but later
reapproved after Chaplain Davis, an ordained
member of the clergy working with the Foundation,
agreed to meet with SCP-166 on a bi-weekly
schedule, every other Sunday.
SCP-166 also requested a telephone, which
she intended to use to contact the Abbess
of the Our Lady of Mercy Convent, a cloistered
society of nuns in County Galway, Ireland.
This request was a little more complicated
to process.
At first it was denied, then granted, and
then denied again after a reconsideration
by Director Light.
But why did SCP-166 want this item?
What connection could the deer girl have to
a group of nuns in Ireland?
The answers lie in the Foundation’s discovery
of SCP-166.
SCP-166 was discovered in the Our Lady of
Mercy Convent, in County Galway, Ireland,
where the girl had been living since infancy.
Her strange appearance and abilities initially
made her the subject of scrutiny by the sisters
who lived there, but she was taken care of,
and raised as a member of the Catholic faith.
When the Foundation was alerted to SCP-166’s
existence, a defecting Global Occult Coalition
agent operating under the codename “Ukulele”,
who was now in the process of joining the
Foundation, confirmed that he recognized SCP-166.
He knew that SCP-166 was the child of an incredibly
dangerous entity, classified by the Global
Occult Coalition as Threat Entity 9927-Black,
a being codenamed "The Goddess".
The Goddess also was being pursued by the
SCP Foundation, and given a designation as
an SCP object, though its number and the exact
details of the file have been redacted by
the Foundation for security purposes.
What we do know is that The Goddess was a
seriously dangerous entity, and both parties
were dedicating as many resources as possible
to its capture, containment, or neutralization.
The conflict between The Goddess, the Global
Occult Coalition, and the SCP Foundation came
to a head during an event known as the Cornwall
Incident.
The Goddess’s file, which was received and
archived by the SCP Foundation has a portion
describing SCP-166, which reads as follows:
“Threat entity is the child of incarnated
LTE-9927-Black ("The Goddess") and an unknown
father.
While it strongly resembles its mother and
shares its animalistic features, it lacks
the extreme bestial appearance of 9927-Black.
Possesses minor chlorokinetic abilities, but
primary reason for threat entity classification
is the instinctive knowledge and eligibility
to enact Occult Procedure Clockwork Blackchild
Havilah, a world-wide ritual working that
would irreversibly regress human civilization
to Neolithic standards.”
“Strike Team "Lancelot" neutralized 9927-Black
in England during an operation which would
later be known as the infamous 'Cornwall Incident',
but were unable to confirm the liquidation
of 9927-Blackchild due to the death of the
strike leader, Agent Ukulele.
Ukulele was posthumously awarded the Silver
Aegis for his lifelong service to humanity.”
As the file stated, SCP-166 is the child of
The Goddess, and the reason for her anomalous
degradation abilities is so that she can enact
them on the world and fulfill her mother’s
unholy mission.
A ritual that would regress society to prehistoric
times, ridding the world of modern technology
and manmade creations.
Why The Goddess wanted to carry out this ritual
is unknown, but SCP-166 was her key to achieving
her primitive desires.
Through her child, she could reach her goals,
but the Cornwall Incident threw a wrench in
the Goddess’s plans.
Agent Ukulele, a Global Occult Agent famous
for decommissioning dangerous anomalies, was
tasked with killing SCP-166.
Perhaps it was her human appearance, or the
fact that she was only a small child, or even
something that lied even deeper.
Ukulele could not bring himself to terminate
SCP-166.
He defected from the Global Occult Coalition,
faking his death and taking SCP-166 alongside
him.
Entrusting her care to the convent of nuns,
Ukulele made himself scarce, relieved that
SCP-166 was safe.
After being free from the Global Occult Coalition’s
grasp, Ukulele was unsure of what to do with
his life.
Taking the name “Alto Clef”, Ukulele had
rid his previous identity from the anomalous
world, and was prepared to start a new life.
But he couldn’t let SCP-166 live unattended.
What if the Global Occult Coalition found
her, and terminated her in an act that would
finish what they had started all those years
ago?
What if the Foundation discovered her?
He didn’t want to risk the girl being put
into a life of containment that she never
wanted.
Clef decided he made the best decision, and
kept SCP-166’s existence to himself as best
he could.
But his hand was forced not long after.
SCP-166, at the age of 12, was seen by a civilian
visiting the convent, who reported her existence
to the authorities.
The Foundation became aware of SCP-166.
Clef, wanting the best for SCP-166, exchanged
valuable Global Occult Coalition intelligence,
documents, and information with The Foundation
in exchange for SCP-166’s containment and
guaranteed safety.
It was the best he could do for the girl.
Clef then fully defected to the SCP Foundation,
where his skills were heavily in demand.
Soon, SCP-166 was retrieved from the convent
and brought into containment.
At least now, Clef could know she was safe.
The Cornwall Incident resulted in the termination
of the Goddess, and all parties were relieved
that the world was rid of this dangerous and
mysterious entity, but it also brought Clef
a significant amount of strife.
Why did he save SCP-166?
Why was the battle-hardened and brutal assassin
unable to kill her?
What connection did Clef share with the Goddess,
if any?
SCP-166 often wondered about the exact details
of her past.
She wasn’t privy to her history with Clef,
or all of the details of her birth, or what
arcane ritual she was born to carry out.
SCP-166 only knew the convent, her faith in
the Catholic religion, and her life in the
custody of the SCP Foundation.
During her talks with Chaplain Davis, she
often discussed these feelings and desires
to know more about herself and her past.
The Foundation kept further details about
the Goddess and her past under restrictive
classifications, and attempts to pry deeper
never bore SCP-166 any fruit.
One conversation between SCP-166 and Chaplain
Davis was particularly noteworthy.
Inside the small confessional, where the two
met every other week, they exchanged greetings
and began talking.
SCP-166 enjoyed her talks with Chaplain Davis,
which allowed her to explore her faith and
further her appreciation of it.
It also gave her an opportunity to talk about
her feelings and thoughts in an environment
similar to the one she was raised in.
To start, Davis reminded SCP-166 that information
she gave him could be reported higher up in
the Foundation, if need be.
In the Catholic religion, confession is a
confidential space, but for the SCP Foundation,
the rules of the church are often broken.
“As usual, I have to remind you that due
to our environment, the seal of confession
will not take place unless specifically invoked.
Even then, details of our conversation can
be unsealed if they're determined to be essential.
Understand?”
Davis said.
SCP-166 understood, and nodded her head.
First, SCP-166 asked a question about a replacement
for Pope Benedict, who had announced his retirement
at the time of the interview.
Chaplain Davis responded:
“Ah, yes, that was rather unfortunate, but
it does make sense.
He was rather old even when he first took
up the position.
Now he can rest, knowing he served the Church
well.”
SCP-166 was curious to know if a replacement
had been decided.
Davis informed her that while there was speculation,
one had yet to be decided for certain.
Though he was sure the Church would want to
go forward with a fresh, new face to broaden
its mission.
SCP-166 seemed pleased at this, but Chaplain
Davis sensed an underlying discomfort in the
girl.
She wasn’t speaking her true feelings.
He assured her that whatever questions she
had, he could answer to the best of his abilities
and without any judgement.
SCP-166 decided to speak up.
She wanted to know if Chaplain Davis had a
good relationship with his parents.
Davis sat back for a moment and thought carefully
about his response, as he did with all questions
that could cause an emotional response in
SCP-166.
No topic was more sensitive for SCP-166 than
the matter of her heritage.
Davis informed her that he maintained a good
relationship with his mother before she passed
away, and a less than happy relationship with
his father.
Davis asked about SCP-166’s parents, diverting
the conversation away from himself.
He wasn’t sure, at this point, exactly how
much SCP-166 was told or knew.
In fact, the Foundation didn’t even let
Chaplain Davis know the full context of SCP-166’s
origins.
“I never really knew my parents,” said
SCP-166.
“I got dropped off when I was a baby.
I mean, I guess they must've known the sisters
if they put me there, but I don't remember
them.
Just what I picked up.
They mentioned my mother a bit, before they
realized that they should watch what they
say about me.
I think they said something about her being
a goddess?
Which obviously wouldn't be true, she must've
been some sort of spirit, but she must've
been something if I ended up looking like
this.
I remember eavesdropping on the Abbess, she
was talking to one of the other sisters about
how she had done something wrong, something
about a ritual that someone else stopped.
They said she died.”
Davis, taken back by SCP-166’s revelations,
told the girl that he was sorry for her loss.
SCP-166 said that it wasn’t like she knew
her anyway, so she wasn’t bothered by it
that much.
Davis asked about her father, but SCP-166
also had little information on him.
She said that she had asked the Abbess about
him multiple times, but she never mentioned
SCP-166’s father.
She wondered, if her mother, the Goddess,
was so horrible, what did her father do that
made him unspeakable?
SCP-166’s questions would not go unanswered.
One day, a letter was found inside her containment
area.
It read:
“I first met your mother when we were little
more than children.
She had hooves for feet and starlight in her
eyes.
She was beauty and nature incarnate, and I
killed her with my own two hands.
Eden isn't a place.
It's a state of being.
They wanted to take us back to it, and I stopped
them.
I took paradise away from us for a second
time.
I have never regretted my actions on that
day, except one: that when you first met me
on that day, you saw your father put a bullet
into the head of your mother.
I make no excuses, only explanation.
You may not have even remembered it, but I'm
telling you now in the hope you understand
why I did what I did.
I hope you forgive me.
I love you.
I wish I could have done more for you.
The best I could do was leave you in the hands
of kind and loving people and hope they would
raise you in my place.
From what I've seen, they did well.
I'm sorry you couldn't stay with them.
I'm sorry they've brought you to this place.
I promise to do my best to make sure your
stay here is pleasant.
I promise to keep you safe.”
“Happy sixteenth birthday, from your loving
father.
Dr. Clef”
Site-19’s Director, Sophia Light, gave Clef
a disciplinary interview for making unapproved
contact with SCP-166 and writing such an emotional
appeal to the girl.
Clef had been barred from talking to SCP-166,
and his superiors were even skeptical about
letting him work at the same site as her.
Light showed sympathy for Clef’s dilemma.
For 16 years, SCP-166, Clef’s daughter,
was unable to live her life normally because
of who she was.
He felt partially responsible.
Despite being one of the Foundation’s most
trusted and powerful agents, capable of sending
a strike team anywhere in the world and knowing
secrets people would pay billions to know,
Clef was unable to talk to his own daughter.
In the end, Clef was subject to a minor disciplinary
infraction, but the hope that he may one day
reunite with his beloved SCP-166 remains.
Now go check out “SCP-407 - The Song of
Genesis” and “SCP-6000 - The Serpent,
the Moose and the Wanderer's Library” for
more nature-inspired SCPs.